here are some actors who literally
joined the picket line to support the
writer strike here's Nina Dobrev across
Warner Brothers Studios Natasha Leon at
a picket line in La Lisa Ann Walter from
ABBA Elementary joined the picketers
outside the ABC Studio Rob Lowe joined
picketers outside of the Paramount
Studios Cynthia Nixon joined the
picketers outside of Netflix's office in
Manhattan Sarah Ramirez also joined
picketers in New York City and Clark
Gregg also joined the New York City
Pickers Angela Kinsey from the office
also supported the strike Alex Borstein
from The Marvelous Mrs maisel and Family
Guy also joined the picketers
Lamour and Morris from New Girl joined
the strike and Jessica Marie Garcia from
on my blog joined the strike outside of
Disney Studios supernatural's Felicia
Day also joined the picketers pageant
Brewster from Criminal Minds also joined
the picket line and Timothy Simons
joined the picket line outside of
Netflix in La these are just some of the
many actors who have shown support for
the wga strike and we'd love to see it